اللغز الذي حير الليبيين،
والسؤال الذي لا يعرفون إجابته،
أين دفن العقيد معمر القذافي؟
ولماذا كل هذه السرية في إخفاء مكان دفنه؟
وكيف دفن القذافي وأين تم الاحتفاظ بجثته حتى دفن؟
وهل كانت جثته وحيدة أم بجانبه جثث أخرى؟
سنوضح لكم إجابات هذه الأسئلة في دقائق هذا الفيديو
، لكن قبل ذلك لا تنسوا الضغط على زر الإعجاب
والاشتراك في القناة وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات
لنستمر بعرض بالمزيد إن شاء الله،،،
عندما استطاع المحتجون، إسقاط القذافي
بدعم من التحالف الأجنبي،
فالعقيد لم يكن بمفرده وكان معه ثلة من جنوده ومرافقيه،
لكن الذين سيطروا عليه، لم يهتموا لباقي جثث الجنود
وأخذوا جثة العقيد ومعها جثة نجله المعتصم بالله القذافي،
وجثة وزير دفاعه أبوبكر يونس،
بعد أن تم إعدامهم،
كان المنتمون لنظام القذافي يرفضون أي تسوية سياسية
إلا بتسليم رفاة القذافي ومن معه،
لكن التحالف أمر أتباعه بعدم تسليم الجثث،
خوفا من أي انقلابات قد تحدث من أنصار العقيد،
وطالت مدة الاحتفاظ بالجثث حتى بدأت بالتعفن،
عندها تم الاحتفاظ بالجثث في ثلاجة للخضرة
في سوق بمدينة مصراتة، حالة الجثث الرثة حينها
أجبرت القائمين عليها، على سرعة إخفاءها ودفنها،
قبل أن تفوح روائحها في المنطقة،
وبعد مرور ٤ أيام على الوفاة والجثث المتحللة
تزداد سوءا، خرج بها القائمون عليها إلى مكان في الصحراء بحسب التقارير
، لكن العملية تمت بسرية تامة،
فتم غسلهم ثم الصلاة عليهم، بإمامة الشيخ محمد المدني الشويرف
الذي كان أسيرا مع المعارضة حينها،
وتواجد في هذه العملية بعض من أعضاء المجلس الانتقالي
بطرابلس حينها وأعضاء من المجلس المحلي بمصراته،
ولكن تم أخذ يمين مغلظ على القرآن الكريم
على كل من حضر، أن لا يبوح بمكان الدفن،
وتم دفن الجثث وإخفاء أي معالم للدفن،
حتى لا تتحول قبور القذافي ومن معه إلى ضريح،
أو أن يتعرض لهجوم من معارضيه،،،
وقال الشخص الذي دفن القذافي ويدعى (أنور صوان)..
أنه استضاف الجثث في منزله في الليلة الأولى
ما منح منزله شرفا ثوريا عظيما كما يقول، ،
دُفن القذافي في الصحراء،
لكن لا يزال من دفنوه يخافون الإفشاء عن مكانه بالتحديد،
فهم يخافون أنصاره، ويخافون من قوة العقيد
حتى بعد مضي أكثر من ١٠ سنوات على مقتله،،